Hi, this is Taryn from Somerville, Massachusetts.
Radiolab is supported by dash digital cash.
The quick and easy way to send money to anyone in the world from anywhere in the
world.
Dash arrives within seconds and transactions are instant secure and optionally
private dash is digital cash. For more information,
visit dash.org/radio lab.
Hey, it's Molly Webster from radio lab. Before we get into the show today,
I wanted to tell you something and that's it. Radiolab has a newsletter. We do.
It's awesome. You should sign up for it.
You'd be the first to know about new episodes.
You'd get updates on old ones and lots more to sign up.
Go to radiolab.org/newsletter see ya.
This is Radiolab.
I'm Jad Abumrad and I'm Robert Krulwich and this hour on radio lab,
we're looking at space more specifically our place in it,
our place in the cosmos. It's big. We're liberal, yes, but since,
as you mentioned before the break,
sometimes artists have their own particular ways of tilting things back in our
favor.
Let me introduce you to someone. Introduce yourself. He's an artist. Oh,
I'm Daria. Roberto. Dario Rigoletto artists live in San Antonio, Texas.
I ran into Darrio actually in New York at the Whitney Museum.
He was 27 and this was his first solo show. My first show here in New York,
first solo show at the Whitney sculpture. Mostly that's his main thing,
but on a sidewall he was displaying some photographs. So tell,
tell me what we're looking at, which I asked him to show me. Oh,
it's a series of seven digital photographs framed on the wall side by side,
seven photos all showing the same thing. Tomato seeds,
seeds that are at different stages of a blossoming. Um,
think back to kindergarten. That's what these remind you of. Your Day.
Your teacher came in and said, okay, class, we're going to grow some seats.
These pictures are of that day.
But more specifically the day the seats actually grew because each photo,
and there are seven shows, one seat,
tiny little seed poking its head out of a massive cup. So what I did was,
these are custom made porcelain cups.
If you can imagine the size of a Styrofoam Cup Darrio made the cops put some
dirt and a seed inside and then cram the top full of cotton cotton,
which is also another school room element. Final step. When the seeds grew,
like right at the moment that they grew, he snapped photos there.
Each one's had a slightly different stage of development, but basically it's,
it's that moment when the leaves are pushing it. Like, you know,
waking up from a long sleep,
which that one kind of looks like yawning and your arms go up in the air. Uh,
also I should point out that there's text printed right on the cups, just as if,
you know,
a kid had written their name or something loopy cursive when you read me with
the names of the people on there. Yeah. So we have, uh, MJ Smith, F, r Scobey,
s c Jay Resnick missions. Maybe you recognize those names. Maybe not. Um,
but here's the backstory. Stereo tells it.
It's 1984 everyone's excited about space and NASA,
NASA built this probe.
It's called the LDF stands for the long duration environmental facility.
This was a probe that was basically meant to store things for long periods of
time. So it had all these compartments, 52 compartments I believe.
And NASA for the first time opened it to the public. It was brilliant PR.
They said, okay America, we've got this probe with all these compartments.
What would you like descend into space? They kind of said,
you send in a proposal for what you'd like to put on board and we'll consider
it. People of all stripes sent in ideas and farms, paint samples,
pond water all the way to a group of school. Kids got together and said, hey,
can we put some seeds on board?
So a NASA is,
I think seeing the great potential in what these children proposed further
experiments of it and put a board,
a lot of seeds for the sole purpose that when they returned they would be
redistributed to the classrooms as a cool, you know,
space seed artifacts. April six, 1984,
the probe filled with seeds and all kinds of things goes aboard the space shot.
It goes a board on, uh,
the space shuttle Challenger launches successfully probe is deployed from the
Challenger and it was scheduled to be picked up on the next shuttle mission by
the Challenger. Well,
the day on that pickup mission was the day the Challenger exploded
coming up on the 32nd point in a countdown.
[inaudible] go for auto sequence start
four three, two, one
don stopped the 25th space shuttle mission and it is cleared the tower,
the major malfunction. The vehicle has exploded.
When you say procedures are in effect
in a flash seven people were gone
and America changed its mind about space and the whole space program got put on
hiatus for I think it was almost two years. And meanwhile that little probe,
the challenger had been on its way to get in,
which was only supposed to be up there for about nine months. Well,
it stayed up there.
This is a case where something literally got lost in space because this is
floating out there. This probe designed for nine months,
ends up sitting in orbit from seven years.
January 19th, 1990.
The probe is finally brought back after seven years by another space shuttle
mission. This time without fanfare,
because all the kids that would've wanted those seeds were grown up.
They didn't know or care anymore. And the only people that did were collectors,
NASA geeks and, and Darrio.
I was able to obtain some of those seeds that were on a board that day through
an online auction. Luckily, they were vacuum sealed the whole time, uh,
but they were incredibly moody little seeds. Uh, they did not want to cooperate.
He planted the seeds in the cotton field cups and the seeds did break through
the cotton, like spaceships bursting through clouds. And right as they did,
he snapped photos, but then days later,
and suddenly they all died. All of them.
So none of these seeds are alive anymore now. And, and I,
I wanted them to, and like I said, they just,
something just wasn't right anymore. I had originally, you know,
wanting to take them to full bloom. It just, it wasn't meant to be,
but getting it here, it was quite a miracle.
So I'll take this the stage
and if you willfully invest in the illusion of a photograph, as Daria does,
this stage means that the seeds and everything,
they represent the lives of the crew, the hope of a class of school kids.
It's frozen alive again
forever, forever.
[inaudible]
again, this is just an art project.
Sometimes reality doesn't cooperate because here's the sad coda to the story.
It turns out the shuttle that picked up the probe in 1990 and brought it back
was the Colombia and just before Darya was preparing to show his [inaudible]
pictures.
Just by coincidence I had the photographs laid out in front of me going over
some framing issues. When the tragedy was first reported
that morning we were breaking in with the sad news this morning.
The space shuttle Columbia has been seen apparently breaking up in the skies
over Texas as it returned to Earth.
Shortly after 9:00 AM eastern time this morning,
search and rescue teams are reporting those. Suddenly the only two shuttles
the seeds ever had anything to do with where the two that we lost.
It really hit me hard.
[inaudible]
Daria over blood was an artist, lives in San Antonio, Texas.
Nobody promised space travel would be safe or pleasant or easy reason.
Rewarding holder was promised was that it would be an adventure and sometimes we
were in the mood and sometimes
we worked well and [inaudible] Carl sagans widow who began the show,
she remembers what it was like the very beginning.
President Kennedy 1962 makes a speech,
which if you read about it in Hurghada tests,
you know that some Persian decreed
that we would walk on the moon,
wait [inaudible] that go to the moon. We choose to go to the moon.
It was the stuff of, uh,
do we choose to go to the moon in this decade and do the other thing?
Not because they are easy, but because they are hard.
They call that goal well serve to organize and measure the best of our energies
and skills because that challenge is one that we're willing to accept.
One we are unwilling to postpone and one we intend to win.
Yeah,
of course. It was in reality,
part of the worst part of the Cold War and the madness of the nuclear arms race.
But it brought out the very best in a whole bunch of people.
And I remember feeling first walking on the moon when Americans first walked on
the moon. You know, I was in raged at my government's conduct in the world.
Horrified by it. But I had to admit that it made me really proud.
And then as soon as NASA became involved with space shuttle,
we lost the grand purpose.
And it was very much to me as a mother of two children remembering when they
were young,
that when they would were toddlers and they were first learning to walk,
they would run away from me and encounter some frightening reality 10 12 feet
away, and then turn around and come running back to be around my ankles.
And that's what the last 25 years of the space program has been like a kind of
retreat to our mother's skirts. Yep.
According to Annie Draughon, somewhere around the space shuttle,
we lost our nerve. Yeah.
Although there is now a new generation of people who would be space explorers
and who say then the loudest possible way.
We don't want to be sissies in space anymore.
But of course we've thought about the government always as the person taking us
there. Okay, this guy, but I put forward here,
the government is not going to get us there.
The government is unable to take the risks required.
Open up this precious frontier. The shuttle is costing $1 billion a launch.
That's a pathetic number. It's unreasonable. That was Peter Diamandis.
Remember him? [inaudible] guy who offered the x prize x prize,
the x prize global contest to build the first commercially manned spaceship.
That space prize, right?
He was at a conference in Oxford in England called Ted Global.
It was an audience filled with entrepreneurs and technologists and he said to
them, you know why I created this prize? You know,
it's really gonna get people interested in space, exploring space,
taking risks in space. Again, as we go forward and here I um,
he's instinct is kind of different from any dreams.
What's gonna bring people back to space, he says, is wealth money? In fact,
the greatest wealth you think about these other asteroids, wealth asteroids,
think how much you make. If you could own an asteroid,
there's a class of the nickel iron,
which in platinum group metal markets alone are worth something like $20
trillion.
If can go out and grab one of these rocks in my plan is actually by puts on the
precious metal market and then actually claim that and go out and get one that
will fund the actual mission to go and get one. Hold on. What a,
what a puts out of those, what you do to finance,
grab in one of those rocks as he puts it.
But the key here remember is that you got to create a business and to do that
you need a business plan. Some reason to invest and build and do for that,
he has actually kind of a cool phrase.
You need what I call an exothermic economic reaction in space,
which in ordinary English means that there's gotta be some way to get
entrepreneurs to spend money, their own money on some kind of space stuff.
And how exactly. Well,
his first notion was he would sell tickets to rich billionaire.
He sold a seat on the Russian space shuttle,
the Soyuz for $20 million, $20 million.
What? It is expensive, but people are willing to pay that.
And then new people I know. Well, but yeah,
I guess you're not going to get a whole lot of people at prices.
So then he came up with a bigger, bolder, broader plan,
which was a prize prize because remember when Charles Lindbergh flew across the
Atlantic, now I don't remember. I wasn't born yet.
Lindbergh cross the Atlantic to win a prize. That's really why you crossed.
Seriously. Yeah. For a cash prize. Peter Thought,
why don't I create a prize of my own?
And he came up with the number 10 million bucks. That would be the prize.
And why 10 million?
Cause it was just big enough to be really attractive to young scientific teams
all over the world.
$10 million and just small enough to be boring to conservative,
clunky companies like Lockheed and Bonnie would never think of anything
interesting. Anyway, he's trying to split the difference I guess. Yeah.
But Peter doesn't have that kind of money. He's not a government. So we're,
do you get a $10 million?
Probably the most difficult thing that I had to do was raise the capital for
this. I went to 102 hundred CEOs, cmos, no one believed it was done.
Everyone said, what does NASA think? What people are going to die?
How can you possibly put this forward?
And what I ended up doing was going out to the insurance industry and buying a
hole in one insurance policy.
You know how rare it is to hit a hole in one on a golf course?
Well the insurance industry will make you a betting proposition.
If you go to the insurance companies, say,
I bet that I can go up and down in space twice in the same two week period.
And they go, Nah, you can't. They said, well,
I'll give you $1 million in premiums if you give me a $10 million insurance
policy. He made the offer, insurance company said, well,
this isn't going to happen. Right?
The insurance companies went to Boeing and Lockheed and said,
are you gonna compete now you're going to compete. No,
no one's gonna win this thing.
So they took a bet that no one would win by January of Oh five and I took a bet
that someone would win.
And Amazingly today,
pilot Mike Melville made aviation history two months before the deadline,
privately funded rocket plane space ship one flew to the edge of space in a
privately funded vehicle. Cool. So and,
and the best thing is that they paid off and, and the check didn't bounce.
Plus he got tons of publicity.
He incentivize young scientists all over the world who did it with other
people's money. But then you just as he was finishing the presentation,
there was this guy in the room who got up and said,
I almost wasn't going to ask this cause I didn't want to end on a negative note.
You know, Peter Diamandis, maybe you're not that brilliant.
Maybe all you are is lucky. Um,
by encouraging innovation. So, uh,
effectively you are encouraging risk-taking and it is inevitable that sooner or
later there will be deaths. The results. Absolutely. And you are also,
it was a little too enthusiastic. Um, you've also made a very, um, uh,
coherent, uh, explanation of why, frankly in PR terms,
investing in prizes is very,
very good value because you got the vast amount of publicity and you're assuming
it's all good publicity. But I can just see the,
again,
the u s broadcast media and the British press media ripping you to shreds
because you've encouraged lots of innocent young 25 year olds from Romania and
Argentinian and whatever to kill themselves. All right, great. Quick onset.
Okay, well it's an important answer guys.
I mean I'm going to pick my hat on as American.
I am thankful that 500 years ago,
thousands of people gave their lives to cross the Atlantic and explore the
Americas and then thankful that that 200 years ago they crossed the great plans.
No one has the right to stay for my children and their children,
that we shouldn't take the risk now to open these frontiers and if it's up to
the individual to risk their life, so be it.
[inaudible]
yeah, but that's, that's, that's the, that was a cop out answer, I have to say,
because when those people,
he's referring to the people crossed the Atlantic crossed the plains when they
did all those things and then when many of them died, I mean thousands of,
I don't know how many thousands. I'm sure now. Anyway, when they died,
those early Americans, they died alone.
There were no TV crammers around. There's no Scott Simon on the radio.
They were by themselves. I think you're right. He's a completely different time.
When you make it sensational, people will die.
Sensationally then what's going to happen to the money and the entrepreneurs and
the businessmen, right? That's exactly right.
Businessmen don't exactly have a sterling reputation for sticking by their guns.
If you have a small financial problem showing up in Brazil,
people all over the world pull their money out of Brazil.
You got a total rush for the exits. It's true.
They're always the first to leave, you know, money and wealth.
It's a good motivators to get us back to space, but once you get there,
it's gotta be about something more than that. Like what though?
Because I agree with you, it's, I don't even know what to call
it exactly, but you certainly hear it.
Take the last transmissions from the moon.
December of 1972 [inaudible] last time we were there. Yeah,
the last time we were there at the voices.
You hear if those astronauts coming back,
when you hear them talking ignition sequence,
all Indians are starting to hear something else.
One Zero we have on that dog. We have a lift on
[inaudible] five is moving on with that Roger
[inaudible] all right. Over to South America and according to that,
looks like government cloud.
[inaudible] Hey, I know. Stop playing. I'm like
[inaudible]. Yeah, I got Delaney type were right over the job of it. No one,
Jerry, I go [inaudible] are we coming in? Oh baby.
Thereby protect John Dancy. That Guy Guy
[inaudible] what's your John Joe that you can fill in America that
[inaudible] [inaudible] we'd like to dedicate the first step of a bottle.
Every pain you're made upon the ball.
Oh my goodness. Unbelievable.
I was enrolling on a moon one day.
May, May.
It's all over.
[inaudible] [inaudible] no man.
[inaudible]
we really ever, we came and God
Willing Romance
[inaudible]
the last transmission from the moon produced by Barrett golden for hearing
voices.com thanks to him.
If you want to hear that again or anything else in the program again,
visit our website, radiolab.org we are now podcasting. Nope.
And also on our website there are a couple of things which didn't make it into
the program today. A little space capsules,
a little artsy little can compositions. Yes. Yes.
So famous people saying what they would send into space.
I know that your favorite, you can find it@radiolab.org and last but not least,
if you want to send us email radio lab at w and Y C. Dot.
Org is the address. I'm Jad [inaudible] I'm Robert Krulwich.
Thanks for listening.